welcome back to the David Pacman show
I'm Farren cousin sitting in for David
packman today well one thing that I've
always been curious about with the uh Q
conspiracy folks you know the whole idea
that the federal government is secretly
being run by this cabal of pedophiles
and that Donald Trump himself was chosen
to weed them out the thing that always
kind of bugs me about this is why are
they So Silent
when actual Republicans get busted
for essentially the same thing they're
accusing the Democrats of doing in the
past five days
we have now seen two
high-profile Republicans
one of them just 19 years old arrested
for allegedly trafficking minors for sex
the big one was last week 30 year old
Anton Lazaro from Minnesota was arrested
on charges of uh well here it is I'm
gonna read this from law and crime the
indictment charges Lazaro with one count
of conspiracy to commit sex trafficking
minors five counts of sex trafficking
miners one count of attempted sex
trafficking of a minor and three counts
of obstruction based on the evidence
obtained in this investigation
authorities believe there may be
additional victims of the alleged
conduct
now Mr Lazaro actually served as an
alternate elector in 2020 for Donald
Trump he has given hundreds of thousands
of dollars to Republican candidates over
the years
and he has been a major player in
Republican politics in the state of
Minnesota
and this report this arrest was so
damning that the Republicans he's
donated money to over the years have
been forced to come out and say well
we're going to donate the money to
charity now uh whatever he had given us
we're going to donate that same amount
to charity hopefully it's Charities that
take care of victims of sex trafficking
but then
actually just a couple miles from where
I'm sitting right now you had another
republican from Minnesota arrested down
here in Florida
um and that person was a 19 year old
Gisela Castro Medina of Saint Paul
Minnesota
she's a leader with the Minnesota
College Republicans which is a governing
group of young political activists her
charges include conspiracy to commit sex
trafficking of minors sex trafficking of
a minor sex trafficking and obstruction
now so she was just elected or just
chosen I guess as a leader of the
Minnesota College Republicans so they've
had to come out and issue a statement
condemning these actions and reminding
people like hey we were all remote last
year so we don't know what's actually
happening but again the question is
where's the cue folks
you say you want to rid the government
of these sex offenders and here's two
fairly high-profile Republicans from
Minnesota
trafficking allegedly children for sex
and people always get annoyed by the way
when you throw out the why do you say
allegedly legally we have to just so
everybody's aware of that okay they have
not been uh Char they've been charged
they have not been convicted so
everything up to that point is allegedly
okay so just so everybody's clear on
that I always get a lot of people saying
why don't you just call them that well
because we don't want to get sued okay
there's your answer but again where's
the cue people hmm
where are you when it's one of your own
where are you on the Matt Gates story
because we got a lot of good information
on that last week all those text
messages the thousands
of pieces of evidence being turned over
by Joel Greenberg the former Seminole
County Tax Collector down here in
Florida with pictures and videos and
text messages directly implicating Matt
gates in a scheme to
buy sex from an underage girl
come on folks I mean I thought this was
what Q was all about
I thought you wanted to bust the
pedophiles
because they're getting busted or at
least the people trafficking for sex are
getting busted
but nowhere to be found right
disgusting disgusting disgusting
behavior and a disgusting conspiracy
theory because yeah you know what
there's some real perverts out there if
y'all put your effort into actually
helping to track these people down and
put a stop to some of these trafficking
rings
that would be worthwhile
but instead you'd rather just push these
wild conspiracies that are driving
people insane
as we saw with the California man last
week who murdered his own two kids
you know what a wasted opportunity if
you actually cared about sex trafficking
victims
you could have done anything to help you
could have put all of this to use for
good
but that's never what this was about
this is about attacking politicians
right
well at least these two got busted and
hopefully if what they're charged with
you know if they actually did it then
yeah hopefully they go away for a long
long time